la bourre mais ça on verra il est 6h30
c'est un dîner par un goûter plus vite
arriver plus vite reparti moi je suis
claqué au loin deux heures c'est plié
tu as pensé à prendre le cadeau oui j'ai
pensé et jets ont dit avoir pensé à ce
que ton parfum days et a aucune chance
que ça déplaise à m
c'est typiquement savait que jamais
merci merci
alors moi j'ai vachement hésité et je me
suis dit comme tu as la chance d'avoir
un frère artiste et je parle de moi là
je parle pas thibault parce qu'il est
drh donc c'est pas trop le même je me
suis dit lemieux venant moi c'était que
je te fasse un petit morceau du coup
j'ai écrit et que j'ai composé mon âme
car caroline c'est ton anniversaire et
je t'aime moi ton frère voilà après j'ai
pas la suite parce que j'ai pas d'autres
humains errent lac albert moi j'ai bossé
toute la journée alors j'ai la tête et
mon père
qu'est ce qu'elle en fait chaque année
qui passe a vieilli d'un long et ça ça
ça craint
parce que j'allais avoir des gâteaux
t'es sûr que ça va pas sans vieille très
très vieille fatigué j'ai fait la taupe
toute la nuit
un mardi mais tu sais c'est normal de
sentir vire et ça arrive à plus de gens
que tu te crois non mais arrête arrête
toi tu fais encore hyper jeune dans sa
tête mais si c'est vrai moi j'arrive pas
faire abstraction comme toi parce que tu
où tout me rappelle que je suis vieille
je paye les transports plein pot by le
ciné plein pot les chansons que j'aime
bien parce sur chérie fm bons mecs mais
baissent quand messieurs revue j'ai
saisi l'idée tu sais on se connaît pas
si bien que ça tout est moins bon que
les détails je suis sûr que vous me
baiser dans l'imposition par mois au
bout d'un moment j'ai passé l'âge pour
certains trucs
ok j'ai 35 ans donc je peux plus la
faire des concerts toute la nuit tout ça
à temps à regarder mais moi j'ai 30 3
bat justement deux ans c'est quand même
c mais regardez même vous m'offrez
d'autres communes qui put enfin sans
vouloir te vexer héros montant que
touche que s'appuie aussi eddy toi j'ai
28 ans et ben j'ai jamais fumé de la
drogue de ma vie jamais wii passe à la
limite
alors terline ton frère à la limite il
en faut plus pour être surpris mais toi
ont peu tenu quand même emballage as tu
de ta tenue
ok c'est mon anniversaire tu peux mais
c'est tout c'est un peu ça te plaît
voilà ce qu'est ce que je veux c'est
envie de manger sans couverts je mange
champs couverts
voilà et j'ai perdu du temps alors je
fais ce que je veux regarde peut même
manger sans les mains qu'est-ce que vous
arrive la sérieuse ne supporte pas que
ces fausses edf
ces lauréats lors de la tendresse que
j'ai même pas tripoter alors maintenant
vous arrêtez de faire ces gueules et ont
fait tranquillement mon anniversaire
parce que regarder thomas il a été clair
attardé mais au moins lui s'éclate
salaires c'est peut-être pas oublier les
filles vous êtes ridicules ont tiré des
gamines au lolo alors ok j'ai compris si
c'est l'équipe des super mes camarades
et moi je propose qu'on fasse l'équipe
des super nanas je peux faire un rebelle